so der deutsche landkreistag schlägt
aktuell alarm denn viele unserer
krankenhäuser stehen gerade kurz vor der
pleite
so unter anderem natürlich wegen corona
dafür muss man betten freiheiten und
operationen verschieben
47 prozent der kliniken erwarten für das
geschäfts jahr 2020 rote zahlen
ja das ist nicht gut das eigentliche
problem reicht aber viel weiter zurück
und zwar ins jahr 2003 als wir mit dem
schwachsinn angefangen haben dass
krankenhäuser profit machen soll
seitdem gibt es das fallpauschalensystem
vorher wurden rechnung nach aufwand um
liegezeit gestellt seitdem gibt es für
jede leistung einen fixen betrag die
implantation eines herzschrittmachers
wird mit 16.000 euro vergütet die
operation an der wirbelsäule bringt
10.000 euro kein wunder dass sich die
zahl dieses operativen eingriffes von
2007 bis 2015 um 71 prozent erhöht hat
ja kein wunder plötzlich haben wir alle
rücken einfach weil man damit geld
verdient deswegen sind corona patienten
kassengift lange liegezeiten keine op
ich meine wenn das wort öffentliche
daseinsvorsorge irgendwo passt dann auch
wohl im krankenhaus was soll denn dieser
profit quatsch nein noch
unternehmensberater der hat ja mit der
versorgung der bevölkerung nichts zu tun
sondern berät für sollten wir den
größtmöglichen gewinn für das jeweilige
unternehmen
und der sagt einem dann bitte schön
machen sie mehr herz und weniger
diabetes genau kein herz für diabetiker
also es sei denn sie brauchen neues herz
klar ja diabetes kann man eh kaum
empfehlen für pflege und erhalt eines
diabetiker fußes gibt es 3000 euro für
eine amputation aber 10.000 da sagt auch
der unternehmensberater unbedingt
abschneiden das teil patientenwohl wird
wahrscheinlich eher überschätzt
je länger diese leute bei dir rum liegen
desto teurer wird es für das krankenhaus
deswegen hat das krankenbett der
neuesten generation einen timer und in
der sekunde in der die klinik mit den
patienten ins minus läuft wird er
automatisch entlassen
badisch das war die landung sei kliniken
profit machen müssen versorgten
natürlich immer weniger personal immer
mehr patienten
ja klar plus die aktuelle mehrbelastung
durch corona und ich sage da sind wir
alle gefragt meine damen und herren
behandlungen die kaum geld bringen aber
zeit kosten müssen wir selber machen
stundenlange vorsorgeuntersuchungen sind
zb quatsch denn mit internet sind wir
doch alle quasi arzt ok google
ich habe hier so ein klub ist das so man
für die angeblich so komplizierte
darmspiegelung brauche ich bloß eine kuh
pro kamera und mainz 11 stick was na
klar immer beherzt rein damit
aus einer espressomaschine einem
thermomix und ein paar metern
gartenschlauch bastelt man ruckzuck ein
astreines dialysegerät und warum teure
krankenwagen kommen lassen
nach kleineren haushaltsunfälle tut doch
auch der eigene pkw für die fahrt zur
notaufnahme
deutsche krankenhäuser von der pleite
bedroht klingt nicht gut aber vielleicht
wäre das auch mal eine chance und zwar
für eine echte reform
experten sagen man käme in deutschland
bis zu 20 prozent weniger kliniken aus
wenn man die verbleibenden personell und
technisch breit aufstellt und ich meine
wenn wir beim reformieren sind können
wir auch den profit zwang abschaffen
also als idee alexander wipprecht ist
chefarzt einer düsseldorfer klinik die
gerade vom manager magazin zu
deutschlands lukrativsten krankenhaus
gekürt wurde herr dr wipprecht
glückwunsch erstmal was ist ihr
geheimnis tempo einfach machen herberg
immer weiter operieren als chirurgen
sprichwort nicht lang schnacken beinahe
packen
ich verliere sogar bares geld werden die
ich hier mit ihnen rummler aber das
heißt ich muss dabei weiter schnippeln
aber keine angst neue herzklappe das
mache ich hundertmal am tag da muss ich
gar nicht mehr hinkommen war doch
herzklappe oder also ein krankenhaus das
geld verdienen will muss in unserem
system eine fabrik seien immer überlegen
was lohnt sich geboten zb braucht kein
mensch dauert ewig stehen stören dann
ziehst du den glitschigen kameraden raus
und die bude sieht aus wie sau
für drei euro fünfzig vielen dank auch
wir wollen neue hüften sachen zum dran
dübel deutschland ist vielleicht nicht
mehr in vielen spitzen aber beim leute
auf see bilden da macht uns keiner was
vor in deutschland wird mehr operiert
als in den meisten anderen ländern
allein 700 1000 eingriffe an der
wirbelsäule und 900.000 herzkatheter
jährlich doch längst nicht alle
eingriffe sind medizinisch notwendig ja
aber finanziell
wir verbauen viermal so viele stunts wie
schweden oder dänemark und doppelt so
viele pässe bei ungefähr gleicher harz
sterblichkeit kann man auch stolz drauf
sein also sie wollen einfach nur jeden
operieren nein natürlich nicht
manchmal zickig patienten auch direkt
nach der voruntersuchung wieder nach
hause dann werden die geräumigen und ich
sehr schätze
aok da kann ich meine chefarzt visite ja
gar nicht abrechnen
das deutsche system ist halt krank was
willst du da machen wir regieren angebot
und nachfrage
dann gibt es teilweise sogar richtig
tages anweisung dann heißt es heute uns
ist heute kurzfristig noch ein platz auf
der gastroskopie ausgefallen wenn sie
meinen patienten ran gehen wir heute
noch castros kopieren können und die
anweisung geht dann regelrecht in die
notaufnahme damit der nächste der sich
halbwegs eignet da passend gemacht wird
wer nicht passt wird passend gemacht und
meine neueste idee wenn einer e betäubt
direkt anderer sachen mit derjenigen die
dem ihr dem laser ich noch die augen und
bist du kriegst auch noch
wir hoffen ins minus
hallo sie sehen ja aus wie einer der
richtig bock hat auf eine
magenspiegelung also bleibt immer stehen
ich rede mit ihnen hatte den mann
aufhalte dem man auf alexander wipprecht
hallo leute ich bin's der heute-show
mime hersteller
wenn ihr mehr heißen scheiß und sie
töten - wollt dann abonniert jetzt den
kanal
was zur hölle ist minimal hersteller
[Musik]